輝達宣佈追加了1500億美元的回購自家股票的授權
那這是美國企業史上最大的一次
這次幹嘛又加這麼多
大家好,歡迎再次收看投資的1006,我是鳳哥
輝達跟臺積電一個是美國最好的晶片公司
一個是臺灣最強的晶圓代工,也是全世界最強
但為什麼他們的股價最近都漲不太動
他們業績很好,口袋很多錢
那那些錢又花到哪裡?
這是我們今天這一集要討論的題目
我們先來看一個很重要的事情
就是9月28號這一天
我們在新聞上看到了兩個很重要的事
一個是
輝達宣佈追加了1500億美元的回購自家股票的授權
這是美國企業史上最大的一次回購授權的增加的金額
那直接又打破了蘋果在2024年的1100億美元的記錄
那另外一個很重要的消息是
半導體呢
大家最重要關心的臺積電
說傳出
這是傳出
說要在美國蓋第二個園區
那第二個園區落腳在美國的達拉斯
這個呼聲現在是最高
預計是要蓋六座先進晶圓廠
總投資金額甚至估計會超過在
在亞利桑那州鳳凰城的2650億美元
所以這個換算成新臺幣呢
就是一個8.4兆新臺幣的一個大數字
一家公司呢是把錢拿來買自己的股票
另外一家呢是把錢拿去美國蓋工廠
所以我們今天跟大家猜解是這兩個
決定他背後到底在盤算什麼
首先呢我們把這兩件事情湊在一起呢
看似不相關
不過是同一個AI浪潮的兩種花錢方式
我們來看 回答他是 輕資產 錢太多
所以他用回購來回答市場對AI泡沫循環融資的質疑
這是過去一段時間以來大家常常在挑戰的
就是你們是不是靠自己的錢在循環
另外臺積電是重資產 他的錢要花在蓋廠
所以他用德州新廠這個新投資
投資人來回答川普的關稅威脅
所以一個是跟華爾街講話
跟投資人講話
另外一個是跟華府講話
跟政治勢力講話
對投資人來說
輝達的回購股票是顯示他口袋還有錢
而且是很多錢的底氣
那這個目標
我覺得是想要救一下股價
畢竟輝達的本益比可以說是直直落
所以投資人就不禁發毛
是有什麼我不知道的壞事嗎
不然匯達本筆為什麼一直往下掉
那臺積電的德州廠呢
就比較像是因應地緣政治風險的保險費再加碼
這確實有可能會壓低臺積電的毛利率
但換來的是未來長期在美國市場的通行證
以及可以避開沒完沒了的關稅威脅
那我們再來看
匯達這1500億美元回購自家股票
這個金額到底有多大
我們來看
1500億
這個是史上最大的增額
追加後
剩餘可回購額度
因為之前它回購了一次
但這個金額還沒買完
所以兩次加起來
有2350億美元
預計執行完畢的時間
會到2028年的會計年度結束
那2027年會計年度
事實上就大部分發生在2026年的日曆年
所以已經執行了大概
398億美元
最近一個會計年度的自由現金流
輝達有將近1000億美元很驚人
口袋真的很深
可是市場更預估
他2028年的會計年度的自由現金流
會來到3290億美元
這是一個更驚人數字
所以輝達真的很有錢
我們大家要注意一個細節
就是前面剛才講到
輝達今年就兩次
大幅的加碼回購這家股票
5月18號加碼800億
這一次又加碼1500億
也就是說5月28號那次都還沒買完
這次幹嘛又加這麼多
你可以等到買完再加
為什麼要急著要加
所以我們來把匯達這幾年的回購授權都排一下
就知道很驚人
你看2024年的8月500億
25年的8月600億
26年的5月800億
到了26年9月居然已經來到了1500億美元
所以這個幾乎每年都有
而且速度還越來越快
我們光看這一次的1500億美元這個金額來講
不要講說兩次加起來有多少
光1500億美元呢
這個金額呢
就大於大概84%的S&P500成分股的企業的市值
也就是說大概有84%的這個成分股的市值呢
都沒有高過1500億美元
所以這個金額之大呢
你大概就可以想像
那輝達為什麼要這麼做
我覺得至少有三層盤算
第一層真的口袋錢真的太多了
而且呢他又不需要蓋工廠
因為輝達是IC設計公司
晶圓是靠這個臺積電在蓋廠在燒錢
所以輝達賺來的錢呢
他不需要大量的投入廠房設備
所以他最近一個快進年度的自由現金流呢
就將近1000億美元
那我們剛才前面講到市場預估兩年後呢
還可能變成3290億美元
這個錢呢與其放在帳上
不如還給股東可以刺激一下低迷的股價
因為我們來看輝達今年到9月28日為止
它的股價上漲大約是22%多左右
可是跟競爭對手AMD Intel比起來真的是遜色不少
因為你知道AMD上漲了183%
Intel更是漲幅來到了214%
所以輝達的22%看起來就是一個很遜色的表現
第二層主要是回應循環融資的質疑
這是我覺得最關鍵的一點
因為在今年7月底的時候
市場就爆出說
輝達正在洽談大概是2500億美元的融資擔保
要協助OpenAI去承租厄埃赫州的資料中心
根據彭博統計
輝達今年以來宣佈了類似這樣的交易
就超過了5400億美元
所以市場的疑慮很簡單
就是輝達他把錢投資給客戶
客戶又拿輝達投資他們的錢來買輝達晶片
那這個買晶片的需求
是真的需求還是自己養出來的
就是我們所謂的循環的融資
所以雖然黃文君9月在高盛的科技大會上面
正面回應說
輝達成長的上限是來自於公益面的問題
而不是需求面的問題
不過嘴巴說就不如真金白銀拿出來給大家看
所以1500億美元的回購
就是在告訴市場
如果你認為我的錢都是左手換右手
那我哪裡來這麼多的錢可以買回自己的股票
所以這是一個他一個信念的一個表達
就是他自己真的很有錢的表達
那第三層呢
就是他可以抵消員工股票造成的稀釋
來撐住美股盈餘
因為科技公司每年會發大量的股票給員工
特別是這幾年呢
因為績效非常好
所以你就會必須發更多的股票給員工
所以股數會持續的膨脹
透過回購可以把這些膨脹的股數買回來
讓每股盈餘不會被稀釋得太嚴重
那這是一個比較技術面的理由
可是長期的股東真的很喜歡你這麼做
我們知道股東看到公司回購
通常絕大多數都是很正面的
不過我們來講一下它的風險
回購固然是好事
代表公司有錢
代表公司對自己的未來有信心
可是我要提醒大家
如果一家還在高速成長的公司
他卻在推動大規模的回購
某種程度代表他目前找不到更好的地方去投資
像蘋果在2024年那次
他1100億美元的回購
建構在的背景是
手機成長已經大幅放緩
甚至手機都可能有一點要面臨衰退
那輝達就不一樣
他明明還在高速成長
公司還預估2028年會計年度的營收
還要在成長約70%
所以這一次就比較像
像我賺太多了 也到處投資了
像臺灣的聯發科都得到了好處
得到匯達將近35億美元的投資
可是就是還有剩錢
不過投資人要記得
回購的授權不一定會買完
就像我們前面講的
他上一次的授權都還沒有買完
所以他只是一個上限
你真正要追蹤的是
最後真的買了多少
而這些錢實際對市場
在產生的刺激的效果又有多少
接下來我們來看的是臺積電
它的德州第二園區是目前還是傳聞
當然我相信大家因為會繼續追這個消息
而且既然會傳出這個消息
也不可能完全都是沒有一點根據
不過臺積電並沒有正式的證實這件事情
所以大家還是要先確認
臺積電並沒有正式的講過這句話
但是這個傳聞有它的邏輯
我們可以來看數字
因為以現在來比較
亞利桑那州2650億美元
那德州傳聞應該會超過這個金額
那規劃內容
前面我們講過亞利桑那州六座經營園場
兩座先進封裝跟一座研發中心
那德州傳聞是六座的先進經營園場
製成當然後發的會更先進
那為什麼在德州的達拉斯會有吸引力
那當地稱為叫細草園
包括德宜 包括三星 包括Coherent 包括特斯拉
其實都已經在那裡設廠
從半導體通訊 公通訊 國防軍工的聚落
其實已經形成了
那臺積電的供應商環球晶
也在達拉斯北邊的謝爾曼市
蓋全美最大的12吋的矽晶圓的生產廠
那臺積電在那邊生產
邏輯上應該有四個盤算
第一層主要當然就是客戶就在美國
因為從2026年的上半年的統計
臺積電的營收大概有差不多75%是來自美國客戶
微達 蘋果 超微 英特爾
全部都要求在美國製造
當然也不是他們堅持在美國製造
而是美國政府要求他們提高在美國製造比例
所以他們被迫一定要在美國製造
客戶在哪裡 工廠就要跟到哪裡
這是一個鐵律
過去是因為實在是在美國生產成本太高了
但現在受到政治壓力你就幾乎是沒得選了
那第二層就是關稅保險
那這是最核心的一個原因
因為9月9號川普又在達拉斯的造勢場合上
點名臺灣
說臺灣今天要賣美國要付100%要付200%
現在幾乎是關稅科多少呢
就是川普突然想到什麼他就說什麼
所以到底會不會變成政策你也不知道
可是那個威脅總是在
但我們要確定就是說
就是說這個所謂的100% 200%
都不是馬上要實施的政策
目前真的實際會生效的是今年1月15號
根據232條款
對特定的高效能運算晶片要加徵25%的關稅
至於第二階段怎麼擴大呢
現在只是一個說法
並沒有真正的定案
不過這裡面還有一個關鍵機制
就是說根據臺美的協議
如果臺廠赴美投資
所產生的這個產能的效益
最高可以得到2.5倍的免稅配額
所以這個意思就是說
如果你在美國的投資越多
你實際生產出來的產能越大
能夠得到免關稅的進口的配額的額度就越大
所以德州第二個園區
它不只是為了要蓋一個能夠生產的工廠
而是在買一個關稅保險
就是亞利桑那時候買完了
現在在買在德州
因為你也不可能過度的集中
在亞利桑那州
因為亞利桑那州現在現實的問題
他同樣有水電跟人才
特別是人才的問題
是一個很大的瓶頸
第三層
就是臺灣自己的水電的供給能力
確實也很有限
因為先進製程確實非常吃水電的供應
所以你把未來一部分產能放到美國
也是在分散臺灣這邊的供給的壓力
第四層
分散地緣政治風險
就不用特別講
這個現在大家都知道
從美國的政府到美國的客戶呢
現在也都很擔心地緣政治風險越來越升高
所以供應業不希望全部集中在臺灣生產
所以臺積電去美國蓋廠
我們知道最大的代價就是毛利率
那臺積電過去在法人說明會上也提過
海外廠會稀釋毛利率
這大家都知道
全臺灣投資人應該沒有人不知道這個道理
但是呢毛利率下降這件事
畢竟是一個可管控的風險
這個代價值得付也應該要付得起
因為如果不去
而你要面對的是關稅風險
以及潛在的地緣政治風險
那這個真的就是很難管控
而且風險可能變得非常高
而且你如果想想
現在美國如果未來整個政黨競爭關係
美國兩黨的政府都競相飆車
要求臺積業要提供更多
所以這就變成一個潛在難以預測的風險
所造成的傷害會遠遠大於毛利率降幾個百分點的這個風險
一句話來總結我們前面講的論點
就是輝達他是用錢來證明自己不是泡沫
臺積電是用錢來證明自己不會被關稅擋在美國市場的門外
接下來我們談股價的影響
就做這些事之後
對輝達跟對臺積電的股價影響是什麼
我們先來看輝達
截至9月28號灰達的股價是228.86美元
如果用過去的12個月獲利來計算
也就是所謂的落後本益比
算出來大概是28.5倍
可是如果你用市場預估的灰達未來的獲利
去算前瞻本益比
這個數字甚至降到只有18倍到19倍
如果你把這個數字放到灰達的股價例子來看
你會覺得那真是非常便宜
因為過去在多頭時期的階段
輝達本益比常常可以達到50倍以上
甚至到70、80倍都有
那一加營收還在高速成長
AI晶片市佔率是基於市場領先地位的公司
前三本益比居然不到20倍
這說真的不太像典型的高成長科技股的估值
輝達本益比下跌主要原因並不是因為股價跌
而是它EPS上升的速度遠快過股價
但這又很矛盾
因為傳統上大多數的成長股的股價漲幅都會強過EPS的增幅
所以現在這種奇怪現象就是所謂的本益比壓縮
也就是市場擔心揮打現在的預估EPS到底能不能實現
AI產業帳面的獲利到底是虛幻的還是真實的
這也就刺激揮打要這麼做
就之前回購還沒買完再加碼
就是因為知道現在市場缺的不是帳面 EPS 而是信心
他用這一招是希望買回投資人的信心
所以我覺得這麼做一定會有激勵股價的成效
但這個效果也沒有達到會讓他大漲的程度
因為目前市場擔心的並不是輝達的口袋有多深
而是整個 AI 鏈的口袋還有沒有錢
接下來看臺積電的股價
我們也用本益比來看臺積電
上半年EPS 49.32元
這是公司臺報
那如果你加上第三世紀的法人的預估
我們來看一下高盛的預估
2026年的全年
高盛預估大概差不多是109元的EPS
所以我們如果換算成本益比18倍
是1962元
本益比21倍是2289元
本益比24倍是2616元
那如果到2027會計年度
高盛預估的EPS來到140元左右
那本益比18倍是2520元
本益比21倍2940元
本益比24倍就會來到了3360元
所以如果我們用9月29號臺積的收盤價
2475元來計算呢
大概就是目前的本益比只有22.7倍
那明年的獲益來算呢
就真的連18倍都不到
這時候就真的很委屈了
因為臺股指數已經創新高了
但臺積電股價沒創新高
所以股價這麼委屈
到底為什麼
我們去找別的原因
因為看起來不是基本面的原因
那是不是籌碼面的原因呢
所以如果我們去分析籌碼
我們會發現
臺積電這段盤整橫盤
沒辦法創新高的階段呢
其實外資爭議來看呢
其實是沒有什麼賣超了
就是買買買買買買
但是賣超並不大
反而是內資縮手
不管是從投信的買賣超
或從融資餘額變化
你都可以看出來
內資追價臺積電現在意願
沒有過去一年多那麼強
甚至我們可以這麼推論
最近幾年外資其實是持續賣出臺積電的
因為外資在臺積電的持股
最高曾經達到78%以上
那本土資金反而是持續買進了
目前外資持有臺積電已經降到70%以下
並且在這裡開始碰到瓶頸
就是外資賣出的這個水位
本土資金的買盤沒有像過去那麼大變慢了
而臺積電的市值就太大
就導致股價推不太動
所以我們可以看到臺股的市場上
那些萬金股甚至五六千七八千的股票還在衝
可是臺積電就不動如山
所以總結來看
AI這場仗還沒打完
但是已經從比技術
到了比口袋跟比未來佈局的階段
所以短線看資金
長線看發展
即使輝達跟臺積電
最近的股價表現平平
可能很多人也蠻失望的
不過它的長期的投資價值
跟長期發展
目前來看還是相當正面
只是說實現這個價值的過程
變慢了變久了
你需要更有耐心
以上就是今天分享
喜歡我們的節目
歡迎幫我們按贊訂閱分享
以及開啟小鈴鐺
謝謝大家